PROFESSOR: Welcome to this
recitation on pure resonance.
So here we're given an operator
p(D) equals D square plus 4I,
where D is the
differential operator
and I is the identity operator.
And you're asked to consider
the equation p(D) applied to x
equals F_0*cos(omega*t),
where F_0 is a constant.
So the first question is
what is the natural frequency
of the system.
The second one is to use the
exponential response formula
to solve for p(D)*x
equals F_0*cos(omega*t).
And here you need to
be careful and do it
for both cases omega equal
to 2 and omega equals not
equal to 2.
And the last question is
just to sketch the graph
for the response of this
system: p(D)*x equals cos 2t,
with the initial conditions x
of 0 and x dot of 0 equals to 0,
basically, rest
initial conditions.
So why don't you pause the
video, take a few minutes,
and work through this problem.
Welcome back.
So first what is the natural
frequency of this system?
So let's just rewrite
our system here.
This is the left-hand side.
So basically, this just
gives us an x dot dot
plus 4x on the left-hand side.
So the system that we're solving
is simply x dot dot plus 4x
equals F_0*cos(omega*t).
So the first question asks
us for the natural frequency
of this system.
The natural frequency
of this system
can be found regardless of what
you have the right-hand side,
just by looking at the
characteristic polynomial
of your equation.
The characteristic polynomial
here would be s squared plus 4.
When this characteristic
polynomial is equal to 0,
we can solve for s and find
what are the natural frequencies
of the system, if basically we
get complex solutions, which
is the case here.
Gives us s square equal minus 4.
So s equals plus or
minus i*2, or 2i.
So the natural frequency of our
system would be omega equals 2,
because we only
consider frequencies
that are positive here.
Second part.
Now, we're asked to
look at the full system
with the forcing on
the right-hand side.
And using the exponential
response formula,
find one solution
to this system.
So here we're talking
about a particular solution
with the exponential
response formula.
So what does the ERF tell us?
The ERF, if you recall here,
the base of it for this system
for example, is the fact
that cosine is the real part
of the exponential i*omega*t.
So we can rewrite this whole
equation as x dot dot plus 4x
equals F_0
exponential i*omega*t.
And we would get then
a particular solution,
if I ignore any particular
value of omega at this point,
which would have the form of
the amplitude that we have
on the right-hand side at
0, exponential i*omega*t,
which is basically our forcing.
Over the characteristic
polynomial of the equation,
so s squared plus 4, evaluated
at the frequency here that
would appear at the forcing
in the exponential form,
so with the i*omega*t.
So here you can see right away
that we would have a problem,
using this formula, if i*omega*t
was a pole or basically a zero,
to this characteristic
polynomial.
And so that's why
you were asked to be
careful with the value of omega
equal to 2 or not equal to 2.
So here let's consider
omega not equal to 2,
so that I can actually write
down 1 over p(i*omega),
because we know that
p(i*2) is equal to 0.
So if omega is not equal to 2,
were out of the danger zone.
And from this point, we can just
basically plug in our values,
i*omega*t, and p(i*omega) would
just give us 4 minus omega
squared.
So here again, the omega equals
2 danger zone approaches,
where we would be
dividing by 0 if we
didn't take the constraint
omega not equal to 0.
So this is the complex form
of this particular solution.
But we're dealing with
a real-valued problem,
so we want to take
the real part of this
to have the solution to
the problem we were given.
And so that would just give
us F_0, 4 minus omega squared,
cosine omega*t.
So now let's take the
case omega equals to 2.
OK So what happens?
If omega equals to 2, this
formula that you're given
fails, and you need to
seek for the derivative
of the characteristic
polynomial.
And we basically have
to-- 2i equals to 2.
So what about p prime of 2i?
So p prime of s is simply 2s.
So if we evaluate p
prime at 2i, we simply
have 4i, which is
not equal to 0.
So at this point we can use the
resonant exponential response
formula that you saw.
Just change my chalk.
We're here.
We would again, same
trick, the cosine
is just the real part
of the exponential.
So we can use this formula.
And we have now to introduce a
t, F_0 exponential i*omega*t,
because we're solving here for
the complex value equation.
And now we can
divide by the p prime
evaluated at 2i, which is 4i.
And so basically, I can
end up with a minus i
at the numerator.
So to take now the
real value solution,
we need again to take
the real part of z_p.
So here now we have an i,
so we need to be careful.
We're going to have
solution in sine.
So let me just write
down what know.
t*F_0 over 4.
This with the Euler formula
would be cosine plus i sine.
The i sine would be
multiplying this i,
the two minus would cancel out.
And so we would end up with
sine omega*t, t*F_0 over 4.
And this would then
give us the solution.
And here, note that
I actually chose
the value omega equals to 2, so
we can even be more explicit.
For this case, we actually
have omega equals to 2t.
So the last part
of the problem was
to sketch the solution for the
initial conditions x of 0 or x
dot of 0 equal to 0, so the
rest initial conditions.
So here are two ways to proceed.
The long way would be
to seek the solution
to the homogeneous equation
without the right-hand side,
the forcing cosine, introduced
two constants of integration,
and then seek these
constants of integration
on the general solution.
And you would find that these
two constants of integration
would be 0 with these
initial conditions.
The other fast way to test
your particular solution
and verify that it actually does
satisfy the initial conditions
that you were given,
and so you can
then right away the solution
as being simply sine 2t.
Here you can see that at 0,
we would have basically a 0.
And then if you do
a differentiation,
you just need to
be careful here,
because you have a
product function,
and you end up also with a 0.
So this actually is
our general solution
for this particular initial
condition, And to sketch this,
we can grow-- so here if I
just pick F_0 equal to 1,
I'm just going to do
t/4 for the envelopes.
At t equals 0, we start with 0.
And we know that we're going to
have the first extrema at pi/4
and the first zero at pi/2.
And so basically, we end up
with something like that.
So basically, it's sine
of circular frequency 2,
and with an envelope
prescribed by t/4.
Or if we had another value
of F_0, it would be F_0 t/4.
So the oscillation
is ongoing as t
goes to infinity
with an envelope that
diverges to infinity.
So this is basically
a solution that
would not be convergent to 0.
So this ends this recitation.
And before I finish, I
just want to point out
that the fact that it
diverges is due to the fact
that we are forcing
this system very
close to its natural frequency.
And so this is a
typical phenomenon
that you can associate
with a resonance,
because we're basically
forcing a system
close to its natural frequency.
So it's having this huge
amplification in the response.
And that's what these
increasing envelopes mean.
So this ends this recitation.
And the key here
was to realize how
to use your exponential
response formula, how to move on
to use the resonance exponential
response formula by testing
for the first order derivative.
And if that test
failed, you would
be going to higher orders.
And then, given an
initial condition,
how to basically
sketch the function
and have a physical
understanding of what
the resonance means.
That ends this recitation.